oh so it's white if if you so if you
play sicilian
or against the ceiling you play you play
knight c3 in
f4 yeah for the longest time that's what
i played like even over the board but
then
um yeah but then people kind of refuted
it so i was like
wait they refused the grand prix maybe
not refute but it just got into a
position that
was not the grand prix anymore oh really
because
like grand prix is hard to prevent if
you're white like
once you once you uh have
this position after knight c3 it's
really hard to prevent
so i'm curious it just goes for an early
d5 pawn break and then
the you know the flank attack just
doesn't work
ah so like e65 yeah
i could show i could show you one
recommendation because you can still
play grand prix
uh so let's say e6 you play f4
they play d5 you can just uh
basically pretend nothing's happening
and just com complete development as
usual
um and you leave the tension in the
center
of course you have to be prepared
because there's different things black
can do here
like black could play d4 black could
take
uh but they're like if if you're
relatively
prepared you'll get comfortable
positions in whatever line
like if takes you you're just adding
development
um yeah and very often you can encounter
the bishop
a lot of players will play d4 thinking
they're they're gaining space but then
you just develop more you have 92 coming
you can still get your grand prix
structure yeah like actually d5
the d4 sabotage is black because you
know that grand prix is
about like the flank attack so if you
close the center um you're just setting
yourself up
yeah this is one of your dreams it's
like get especially if knight c6 here
you can take
play knight e2 and then you get kind of
a super solid pawn formation
and this structure is terrible for black
on the queen side
um i can share one more cool line and
maybe this would be beneficial for
people watching too
who play a similar opening as white uh
is
usually black will play
uh knight c6 here which is like the most
flexible move
and keeping all the pressure then you
can play bishop b5
and one of your main goals you want to
take and and still like damage black
structure
it's very much worth giving away the
bishop hair
and black can't quite play bishop d7
because then you
you just win the pawn on d5 if black
pushes again you take and play knight e2
so most people try knight e7
and then there's a really cool idea you
take takes
in queen e2 and i don't know if you ever
like maybe studied this line
specifically
um but if you're like something i'd play
yeah yeah it's um there was a book
written on the grand prix by gawain
jones
it was actually also a streamer played
sometimes on chess.com
um but he went like very in depth into
like a whole repertoire
and recommends this as like a tricky
variation and the whole point you're
pinning the knights
on e7 so you're threatening to take
again and damage the the structure
um and then there's some additional
tricks uh
like if black tries to break the pin
again you win the pawn because the
knight's pinned
um if g6 which looks kind of logical to
fiancado
you have a cool move queen e5 just
preventing
basically provoking rook g8 preventing
black from castling
and then if black tries to like break
the e file
with bishop e6 you can still take on c6
because if knight takes you you have f5
yeah
so it's just a cool idea that like if
this is one of
your biggest pet peeves is black going
for this e65 you can still be prepared
with some tricky line
it's effective against uh like against
some master level players
not too many players study the specific
line so hopefully that helps in some way
yeah yeah i'll i've never given up on
the grand prix it's just i've toned back
a little bit
uh yeah it's good to diversify mm-hmm
for sure
but yeah it's grand prix it's like i
discovered this opening
when i was rated around 2000 it was one
of the main openings which helped me
go from 2000 to 2200 i had a few like
tournaments where it helped me get from
like
1500 to 2000 and my coach was like no
it's not good anymore like you're
playing high high-rated players
yeah i mean it's one of those openings
like it's good to incorporate your in
your repertoire like if you're an e4
player
at some point um but usually the road to
improvement you want to like be able to
understand different sort of structures
and not
not stick with it for i guess entirety
of your chess career
for sure